en este vídeo vamos a conectar nuestro
controlador del motor a nuestro arduino
y para hacerlo necesitamos identificar
las conexiones de cada uno de los cables
para así saber a dónde conectar cada uno
configuramos nuestro multímetro a
abierto lo que nos permitirá identificar
la continuidad de una conexión cuando
escuchen la campanita quiere decir que
tenemos un flujo continuo de electrones
y nos permitirá identificar cuál cable
es cuál si no escuchamos la campanita
entonces no es el mismo cable pero
cuando la escuchamos significa que si es
el mismo cable y es así como los
identificamos usando nuestro multímetro
tomamos este cable que es el e1 y ya
hicimos una lista de a dónde queremos
que vaya cada cable nuestro cable l uno
va a ir al pin de 10 entonces vamos a
usar esta lista para cuando queramos
programar esto en la computadora y así
sepamos cuál línea tiene cuál cable en
el código y esto nos ayudará a programar
correctamente nuestras funciones y ya
hemos conectado el primer cable y ahora
vamos con el cable que sigue y de nuevo
usaremos nuestro multímetro el cable que
sigue es el 2 y lo vamos a conectar al
pin digital
encendemos nuestro multímetro y lo
ponemos en abierto para encontrar cuál
de los cables es l 2
este es
es el segundo cable de aquí
y en nuestra lista dijimos que el 2 y va
a ir en de 8 conectamos los demás cables
siguiendo el mismo procedimiento
identificando cada cable mediante su
continuidad y luego conectándolo al pin
que determinamos en la lista si van a
usar el mismo código que nosotros
asegúrense de conectar los cables en el
mismo orden de esta lista la cual
publicaremos en línea como pueden ver
aquí nos equivocamos con lo que íbamos a
conectar en de 9 y por eso lo tachamos
de 9 no lo vamos a usar en el siguiente
vídeo veremos como cablear la cámara y
la tarjeta de sonido